Let's assume that you want to send a message from
Atlanta to San Francisco. And to make it easier, let's
assume that we want to send a simple message which
consists of n coin flips, or the output of ten coin
flips. Let us construct two messages out of coin flips.
Now, I have two coins, but you see these coins
are different because this one has a heads and a
tails, it has two different sides, And this one has both
the sides which are very similar looking. So its a
biased coin so every time I flip its going have
the same state. While when I flip this it might
either end up here, 50% of the time or end
up here 50% of the time. So we'll construct two
messages after flipping both of them and recording what their
state is. So here it is, I did ten coin
flips with the fair coin I got a few heads,
a few tails, in this particular sequence. The unfair
coin, I'm calling every state as a head state and
I basically saw ten heads. All right? If you
also observe the fair coin I have like five heads
and five tails. So the probability, so it, so it wa, so it is a fair coin. I got
five heads and five tails, so it is a
fair coin. So, if I had to transmit this sequence,
how many bits of message will I require? Let's
assume that I can represent this sequence using ten
binary digits. A zero representing heads, one representing tails
and I can write down this sequence as zeros
and ones using ten bits. I can also write
down the same sequence with the, of the unfair
coin using those ten binary digits. So I'll get
something like zero, one, zero, zero, one, zero, one.
And here, everything will be zeros. Let's assume I have to transmit
these two particular sequences from Atlanta to San Francisco. What will be
the size of each message in case of the fair coin and
the unfair coin? What do you think? Write down your answers here.